let's talk about a game
you mean one of the greatest games ever
made i know you could talk about doing
quake and so on but to me wolfenstein 3d
was like wow
it blew my mind that that world like
this could exist so how did wolfenstein
3d come to be
uh in terms of the programming in terms
of the design in terms of some of the
memorable technical challenges
um
and also actually just something you
haven't mentioned
you know
how do these ideas
come
to be inside your mind the adaptive side
scrolling so the solutions to these
technical challenges
so i usually can introspectively pull
back
pretty detailed
accounts of how technology solutions and
design choices on my part came to be
where
i technically we had done two games 3d
games like that before where hover tank
was the first one which had flat shaded
walls but did have the scaled enemies
inside it and then catacombs 3d which
had textured walls scaled enemies and
some more
some more functionality like the
disappearing walls and some other stuff
but what's really interesting from a
game development standpoint is
those games catacombs 3d puffer tank and
wolfenstein
they literally used the same code for a
lot of the character behavior that a 2d
game that i had made earlier called
catacombs did
where it was an overhead view game kind
of like gauntlet you're running around
and you can open up doors pick up items
basic game stuff
and the thought was that
this exact same game experience just
presented in a different perspective it
could be literally the same game just
with a different view into it would have
a dramatically different impact on the
players
so it wasn't
it wasn't a true 3d you're saying that
you could kind of fake it you can like
scale enemies meaning things that are
farther away you can make them smaller
so from the game was a 2d map like all
of our games used the same tool for
creation and we used the same map editor
for creating keen as wolfenstein and
evertank and catacombs and all this
stuff so the game was a 2d grid
made out of blocks and you could say
well these are walls these are where the
enemies start then they start moving
around and these early games like
catacombs you played it strictly in a 2d
view it was a scrolling 2d view and that
was kind of using an adaptive tile
refresh at the time to be able to do
something like that and then
the thought that these early games all
it did was take the same basic enemy
logic but instead of seeing it from the
god's eye view on top you were inside it
and turning from side to side yawing
your view and moving forwards and
backwards and side to side i and it's a
striking thing where you always talk
about wanting to isolate and factor
changes in values and this was one of
those most pure cases there where
the rest of the game changed very little
it was our normal kind of change the
colors on something and draw a different
picture for it but it's kind of the same
thing but the perspective changed in a
really fundamental way and it was
dramatically different i can remember
the reactions where the artist uh adrian
that had been drawing the pictures for
we had a cool big troll thing in
catacombs 3d and we had uh these walls
that you could get a key and you could
make the blocks disappear get really
simple stuff blocks could either be
there or not there so our idea of a door
was being able to make a set of blocks
just disappear
and i remember the reaction where he had
drawn these characters and he was slowly
moving around and like people had no
experience with 3d navigation it was all
still keyboard we didn't even have mice
set up at that time but slowly moving
going up picked up a key go to a wall
the wall disappears in a little
animation and there's a monster like
right there and he practically fell out
of his chair it was just like ah
and
games just didn't do that you know the
games were the god's eye view you were a
little invested in your little guy you
can be like you know happy or sad when
things happen but you just did not get
that kind of startle reaction you
weren't interested in your face
something in the back of your brain some
reptile brain thing is just going oh
[ __ ] something just happened
and that was one of those early points
where it's like yeah this is going to
make a difference this is going to be
powerful and it's going to matter were
you able to imagine that in the idea
stage or no so
not that exact thing so again we had
cases like the arcade games battlezone
and star wars that you could kind of see
a 3d world and things coming at you and
you get some sense of it but nothing had
done the kind of worlds that we were
doing and the sort of action based
things 3d at the time
was really largely about the simulation
thoughts and this is something that
really might have trended differently if
not for the id software approach in the
games where
there were flight simulators there were
driving simulators you had like hard
drive-in and microsoft flight simulator
and these were doing 3d and general
purpose 3d and ways that were more
flexible than what we were doing with
our games but they were looked at as
simulations they weren't trying to
necessarily be fast or responsive i were
letting you do kind of exciting
maneuvers because they were trying to
simulate reality and they were taking
their cues from the big systems the
evans and sutherlands and the silicon
graphics that were doing things but we
were taking our cues from the console
and arcade games you know we wanted
things that were
sort of quarter eaters that were doing
fast-paced things that you could smack
you around rather than just smoothly
gliding you from place to place
so quarterly yeah
and you know the funny thing is so much
that that built into us that wolfenstein
still had lives and you had like one of
the biggest power-ups in all these games
like was an extra life because you
started off with three lives and you
lose your lives and then it's game over
and there weren't save games in
most of this stuff it was
it sounds almost crazy to say this but
it was an innovation in doom to not have
lives you know you could just play doom
as long as you wanted you just restart
at the the start of the level and why
not this is like we we aren't trying to
take people's quarters they've already
paid for the entire game we want them to
have a a good time and you would have
some i you know some old timer purist
that might think that there's something
to the epic journey of making it to the
end having to restart all the way from
the beginning after a certain number of
tries but now more fun is had when you
just let people kind of keep trying when
they're stuck rather than having to go
all the way back and and learn different
things so you've recommended the book
game engine black book wolfenstein 3d
for technical exploration of the game so
looking back
30 years what are some memorable
technical innovations that made
this perspective shift into this world
that's so immersive that scares you when
a monster appears or some things you
have to solve
so one of the interesting things that
come back to the theme of deadlines and
resource constraints the the game
catacombs 3d um
we shipped we were supposed to be
shipping this for gamer's edge on a
monthly cadence and i had slipped i was
actually late it slipped like six weeks
because this was texture mapped walls
doing stuff that i hadn't done before
and at the six week point it was still
kind of glitchy and buggy there were
things that i knew that if you had a
wall that was like almost edge on you
could slide over to it you could see
some things freak out or vanish or not
work and i hated that i i but i was up
against the wall we had to ship the game
uh it was still a lot of fun to play it
was novel nobody had seen it it gave you
that startle reflex uh reaction so it
was worth shipping but it had these
things that i knew were kind of flaky
and janky and not uh not what i was
really proud of so
one of the the things that i did very
differently in wolfenstein i was i went
catacombs used
almost a conventional thing where you
had segments that were one-dimensional
polygons basically that were clipped and
uh and back-faced and done kind of like
a very crude 3d engine from the
professionals but i wasn't getting it
done right i was not doing a good enough
job i didn't really have line of sight
to
um to fix it right there's stuff that of
course i look back it's like oh it's
obvious how to do this and do the math
right do your clipping right
check all of this how you handle the
precision but i did not know how to do
that at that time
the first 3d engine you wrote kind of
comes 3d
and hovertank had been a little bit
before that but that had the flat shaded
walls so the texture mapping on the
walls was what was bringing in some of
these challenges that was uh that was
hard for me and i couldn't solve it
right at the time can you describe what
flat shading is in texture mapping so in
the the walls were solid color one of 16
colors i in hover tank so that's easy
it's fast you just draw the solid color
for everything texture mapping is what
we all see today where you have an image
that is stretched and distorted onto the
walls or the surfaces that you're
working with um
and it was you know it was a long time
for me to just figure out how to do that
without it distorting in the wrong ways
and
and i did not get it all exactly right
in catacombs and i i had these flaws
so that was important enough to me that
rather than continuing to bang my head
on that when i wasn't positive i was
gonna get it i went with a completely
different approach for drawing for
figuring out where the walls were which
was a raycasting approach which i had
done in catacombs 3d i had a bunch of c
code trying to make this work right and
it wasn't working right in wolfenstein i
wound up going to a very small amount of
assembly code so in some ways there
should be a slower way of doing it but
by making it a smaller amount of work
that i could more tightly optimize it
worked out and wolfenstein 3d was just
absolutely rock solid you know it was
you know nothing glitched in there the
game just was pretty much flawless
through all of that and i was super
proud of that i'm
but eventually like in the later games i
went back to the more span-based things
where i could get more total efficiency
once i really did figure out how to do
it so there were two sort of key
technical things to wolfenstein one was
this raycasting approach which you still
to this day you see people go and say
let's write a raycasting engine because
it's an understandable way of doing
things that let you make games very much
like that so you see raycasters in
javascript raycasters and python people
that are are basically going and
re-implementing that uh that approach to
taking a tiled world and casting out
into it it works pretty well but it's
not the fastest way of doing it can you
describe what raycasting is
so you start off and you've got your
screen which is 320 pixels across at the
time if you haven't sized down in the
window for for greater speed and at
every pixel there's going to be an angle
from you've got your position in the
world and you're going to just run along
that angle and keep going until you hit
a block
so
up to 320 times across there it's going
to throw a cast array out into the world
from wherever your origin is until it
runs into a wall and then it can figure
out exactly where on the wall uh it hits
the performance challenge of that is as
it's going out every block it's crossing
it checks is this a solid wall so that
means that in like the early wolfenstein
levels you're in a small jail cell going
out into a small hallway it's super
efficient for that because you're only
stepping across three or four blocks but
then if somebody makes a room that
covers our maps we're limited to 64 by
64 blocks if you made one room that was
nothing but walls at the far space it
would go pretty slow because it would be
stepping across
80 tile tests or something along the way
by the way the physics of our universe
seems to be competing this very thing so
this maps nicely to the actual physics
of our world yeah you get intuitive i
follow a little bit of something like
stephen wolfram's work on i've you know
interconnected network information
states of that and that's it's beyond
what i can have an informed opinion on
but it's interesting that people are
considering things like that and have uh
and have things that can back it up yeah
that's yeah there's whole different sets
of interesting stuff there so
wolfenstein 3d had raycast raycasting
and then the other kind of key aspect
was what i called compiled scalars where
the idea of
you saw this in the earlier classic
arcade games like space harrier and
stuff where you would take a picture
which is normally drawn directly on the
screen and then if you have the ability
to make it bigger or smaller big chunky
pixels or fizzly small drop sampled
pixels
that's the fundamental aspect of what
our characters were doing in these 3d
games you would have it's just like you
might have drawn a tiny little character
but now we can make them really big and
make them really small and move it
around
that was the limited kind of 3d that we
had for characters to make them turn
they were literally eight different
views of them you didn't actually have a
3d model that would rotate you just had
these cardboard cutouts but that was
good enough for that startle fight
reaction and it was kind of what we had
to do deal with there so a
straightforward approach to do that you
could just write out your doubly nested
loop of i you've got your stretch factor
and it's like you've got a point you
stretch by a little bit it might be on
the same pixel it might be on the next
pixel it might have skipped a pixel um
you can write that out but it's not
going to be fast enough where especially
you get a character for that right in
your face monster covering almost the
entire screen doing that with a general
purpose scaling routine would have just
been much too slow it would have worked
when they're small characters but then
it would get slower and slower as they
got closer to you until right at the
time when you most care about having a
fast reaction time the game would be
chunking down
so the fastest possible way to draw
pixels
at that time
was to i am
instead of saying i've got a general
purpose i am
version that can handle any scale
i made i i used a program to make
essentially a hundred or more separate
little programs that was optimized for i
will take an image and i will draw it 12
pixels tall i'll take an image i'll draw
it 14 pixels tall up by every 2 pixels
even for that so you would have the most
optimized code so that in the normal
case where
most of the world is fairly large i like
the pixels are big you know we did not
have a lot of memory so in most cases
that meant that you would load a pixel
color and then you would store it
multiple times
so
that was faster than even copying an
image in a normal conventional case
because most the time the image is
expanded so instead of doing one read
one write for a simple copy you might be
doing one read and three or four writes
as it got really big and that had the
beneficial aspect of just when you
needed the performance most when things
are covering the screen it was giving
you the most acceleration for that by
the way were you able to uh
understand this through thinking about
it or were you testing like the right
speed and like this again comes back to
i can find the antecedents for things
like this so in i'm
back in the apple two days i'm the
graphics were
essentially single bits at a time and if
you wanted to make your little spaceship
if you wanted to make it smoothly go
across the world if you just took the
image and you drew it out at the next
location you would move by seven pixels
at a time so it would go chunk chunk
chunk if you wanted to make it move
smoothly you actually had to make seven
versions of the ship that were
pre-shifted you could write a program
that would shift it dynamically but on a
one megahertz processor that's not going
anywhere fast so if you wanted to do a
smooth moving fast action game you made
separate versions of each of these
sprites now there are a few more tricks
you could pull that if it still wasn't
fast enough you could make a compiled
shape where instead of this program that
normally copies an image and says like
get this byte from here store it here
get this byte store this byte if you've
got the memory space you could say i'm
going to write the program that does
nothing but draw this shape it's going
to be like i'm going to load the
immediate value 25 you know which is
some bit pattern and then i'm going to
store that at this location uh rather
than loading something from memory that
involved indexing registers and this
other slow stuff you could go ahead and
say no i'm going to hard code the exact
values of all of the image right into
the program now this was always a
horrible trade-off there but you didn't
have much memory and you didn't have
much speed but if you had something that
you wanted to go really fast you could
turn it into a program
and that was you know knowing about that
technique is what made me think about
some of these unwinding it for the pc
where people that didn't come from that
background were less likely to think
about that
i mean there's some deep parallels
probably to human cognition as well
there's something about
optimizing and compressing
the the processing of a new information
that requires you to predict the
possible ways in which
the game or the world might unroll and
you have something like compiled scalars
always there so if you have like optima
like you have a prediction of how the
world will unroll and you have some kind
of optimized
data structure for that prediction and
then you can modify if the world turns
out to be different you can modify it
slightly as far as building out
techniques so much of the brain is about
the associative context you know they're
just when you learn something it's in
the context of something else and you
can have faint tiny little hints of
things and i do think there are some
deep things uh you know around like
sparse distributed memories and boosting
that's like if you can just be slightly
above the noise floor of having some
hint of something you can have things
refined into pulling the memory back up
so having a being a programmer and
having a toolbox of like all of these
things that things that i did in all of
these previous lives of programming
tasks that still matters to me about how
i'm able to pull up some of these things
like in that case it was something i did
on the apple ii then being relevant for
the pc and i have still cases when i
would when i would work on mobile
development then be like okay i did
something like this back in the the doom
days but now it's a different
environment but i have still had that
tie i can bring it in and i can
transform it into what the world needs
right now
and i i do think that's actually one of
the very core things with human
cognition and brain like i you know
brain like functioning is finding these
ways about you've got your brain is kind
of everything everywhere all at once you
know it's it is just a set of all of
this stuff that is just fetched back by
these queries that go into it and they
can just be slightly above the noise
floor with random noise in your neurons
and synapses that are affecting exactly
what gets pulled up so you're saying
some of these very specific solutions
for different games
you find that there's a kernel of a deep
idea that's generalizable to other
to other things yeah you can't predict
what it's going to be but that idea of
like i called out that compiled shaders
uh in the forward that i wrote for that
uh the game engine black book as you
know this is it's kind of an endpoint of
unrolling code but that's one of those
things that thinking about that and
having that in your mind and i'm sure
there are some programmers that you know
hear about that think about it a little
bit it's kind of the mind-blown moment
it's like oh you can just turn all of
that data into code and nowadays you
know you have instruction cache issues
and that's not necessarily the best idea
but there are different
it's an idea that has power and has
probably relevance in some other areas
maybe it's in a hardware point of view
that there's a way you approach building
hardware that has that same you don't
even have to think about iterating you
just bake everything all the way into it
in one place
you